do you enjoy the beautiful views of
horizon zero dawn a post-apocalyptic
world well then you'll be happy to hear
that the excellent action game is
getting a big update next week I'm Matt
and this scheme spot news update is
ready to jump back into the robot
infested wild horizons next update
improves the game's photo mode by adding
three new filters a grid overlay and a
greetings for a message that can be
applied to photos on top of that players
will be able to choose different poses
for main character alloy while also
selecting whether or not she looks at
the camera in addition to those new
features the update adds a lot more
customization options for the HUD you
can check out the full list of features
on gamespot comm but before you do that
make sure to LIKE and subscribe for all
the videos and news on the ps4's
exclusive games horizon zero dawn
received a 9 out of 10 in our review
GameSpot's peter brown said that for
every minor imperfection there's an
element of greatness that recharges your
desire to keep fighting and exploring 0
Dawn's beautiful and perilous world
we'll keep you updated on everything
horizon but if you want to check out a
different PlayStation exclusive game
then watch our live stream of Neos DLC
adventure dragon up the north
[Music]
you